peur de personne merci merci la parole
et à monsieur dominique tian merci le
seul président la question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la santé madame la
ministre depuis plusieurs semaines vous
parcourez les plateaux de télévision
pour annoncer que vous avez sauvé la
sécurité sociale
c'est un c'est un mensonge d'état
la situation est catastrophique
comment vous pouvez vous cacher aux
français le montant du trou de la sécu
qui s'élèvera à 152 milliards d'euros
152 milliards d'euros la dette des
hôpitaux seraient déjà 30 milliards
d'euros et celle des régimes spéciaux à
plus de 6 milliards
la situation au contraire est dramatique
et la cour des comptes vient 12 ans de
vous le rappeler
ainsi que le comité d' alerte de l'ondam
vous êtes tellement aux abois madame la
ministre que vous restreignez même
l'aide aux chômeurs qui veulent sortir
du chômage en créant leur propre
entreprise vous en prenez aussi à
l'économie collaborative dit économie de
partage
ainsi mes chers collègues toute personne
qui à partir du 1er janvier 2017 mettre
en location sa voiture son camping car
son bateau son combi pour faire plaisir
à monsieur ayrault à partir d'une somme
de 3800 euros par an devra
obligatoirement se déclarait comme un
professionnel et devra s'affilier
obligatoirement au rsi donc à chacun
connaît la réputation alors que ces
personnes paient déjà des impôts sur ses
recettes
ils devront payer des cotisations à
partir du 1er avril 2017
vous êtes également tellement aux abois
madame la ministre que vous avez failli
taxer les chèques vacances versées par
les comités d'entreprise aux salarié es
una vers lancé au dernier moment que
sous la pression populaire
madame la ministre pour votre dernier
projet doit être social comptez-vous
après cinq ans d'inaction écouter
l'opposition pour le pas grave et la
situation et enfin dire la vérité aux
français sur l'état de nos comptes
sociaux
la parole là par l'état monsieur
christian eckert secrétaire d'état
chargé du budget merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député dominique
tian sur la question du déficit de la
dette
c'est un discours habituel et à défaut
de vous mettre d'accord sur vos
programmes au moins essayons de nous
mettre d'accord sur les constats s'agit
là de constats il ne s'agit pas là de
deux projets sur la question que vous
posez sur l'économie collaborative el
merrikh évidemment une attention
particulière du parlement notre société
notre économie évolué personne n'aurait
idée ici de revenir sur le développement
d'un sonnantes d'activité des secteurs
d'activités économiques importants qui
correspondent aux besoins du jour
personne n'aurait ici d'idées non plus
de faire en sorte que l'émergence de
nouvelles formes de commerce des changes
ou de travail puis ce obérer l'exercice
j'allais dire plus traditionnels son
appel généralement l'économie réelle par
une concurrence qui ne serait pas
équitable qui ne serait pas égales
certains exemples connus nous le
rappelle je parlais du beurre je parais
darby nbi et lorsque l'on rencontre des
artisans des commerçants les hôteliers
restaurateurs par exemple ce sont les
sujets qu'ils nous posent avec raison et
le financement de la protection sociale
la relation au travail indépendant des
questions fiscales impose effectivement
une réflexion du parlement ce n'est pas
nouveau tout les députés ici et pascal
terrasse et d'autres ayant travaillé
nous devons réfléchir
effectivement à la nécessité ou pas de
s'affilier à partir de quel moment
partir de quel seuil à partir de quel
seuil d'activité définir le partage de
frais définir ce qu'est le revenu cette
a7 à ce travail que nous appelons le
parlement
les seuils monsieur le député peuvent se
discuter je les dis ici de lors de la
discussion générale